لذلك دعنا ننتقل إلى Twitter لمدة دقيقة فقط
وسنعود إلى هذه الأشياء
التي تهمني أكثر
فأنا أحاول الخروج من الصفقة
جيدًا لقد أخبرتني لماذا لا يتعين عليك
الخروج
[موسيقى]
أنا  أعتقد أن هناك قدرًا هائلاً من
إمكانات
[الموسيقى]
ولكن سيكون من الصعب جدًا
تحقيقها ولكن أعتقد أنه من الممكن وأعتقد في
النهاية أنها قد تكون واحدة من أكثر
الشركات قيمة في العالم من
كبار المعلنين الأجانب [للموسيقى] للتوقف عن إنفاق الأموال
على Twitter ،
هذا على الرغم من قيامنا بكل ما هو
ممكن لإرضائهم
وتوضيح أن قواعد الاعتدال
وقواعد السلوك البغيض لم تغير هذا
لا يبدو صحيحًا
لأننا لم نقم بأي تغيير في عملياتنا
على
الإطلاق ولكن مع ذلك  نجحت مجموعات الناشطين
في التسبب في
انخفاض كبير في إيرادات إعلانات Twitter
[موسيقى]
معاداة السامية أو العنصرية أو أي شيء من
هذا القبيل جيدًا ، أعني إذا كان من سيبقى
على منصة إذا كان ذلك أجنبيًا سائدًا